pick up were you hiding I wonder where  Jacob could be I pronounce you husband  and wife are usually under a chart  [Music]  it's mark how's Elizabeth in that  grandson of mine divorced dad Jacob's  dead seven years ago today Elizabeth I  wanted let you know that I'm selling the  house call me back on this number  [Music]  I saw my dead son in the house what is  he doing here in the land of the living  he was money I need to talk to you look  I don't really have time to chat it's  about taker I knew you'd come you can't  touch him wow this is possible do you  know why you're here I won't keep he's  lost he needs you to help him move on  you don't get to take him away from me  again what are you talking about my  father there's my phone I wanted to be  like before we deserve to be happy  you can't keep him here this world is  for the living  or something house today not just today  [Music]  is it possible to close whatever door is  open  [Music]  you should be afraid  you